yeah you guys should all go watch the
conversation with Lex Freeman I thought
Lex handled it really well great yeah I
thought he was I thought he was great
but I thought he exposed like a side of
Kanye that I wasn't familiar with
and
and he did it with like Grace and and
empathy and and Lex it felt like he was
upset like visibly it felt like he was a
friend who was disappointed in Kanye
yeah but also angered at times and then
he kind of controlled his anger like Lex
is a [ __ ] black belt in Jiu Jitsu if
he wanted to twist Kanye's head off his
shoulders he could do it in a [ __ ]
heartbeat yeah he looks like a dweeb but
he's not he could [ __ ] somebody up yeah
and um so it's like Al goes hmm of
course racism
because he's Jewish
he's Ukrainian until he [ __ ] you up he
can't move in that suit it's going to
keep him low
so so basically I think what he exposed
in Kanye is this uh
unbelievable
hurt and loneliness
and I think Kanye has been [ __ ] over
by a lot of people in the business now
where did you pick up on this please uh
how much of the episode hour and ten
hours yeah so it's about like like a two
and a half hour so you'll start to feel
a little bit more but like he starts
there's a moment where he tells uh uh
Lex and uh he tells them I don't trust
you
you have to trust people and so he goes
I don't trust you and like Lex is like
thrown by it he goes I'm sorry I was
like really thrown off by that like that
no one's ever told me that they don't
trust me that's great for me and that
like hurt me that you said that like he
just had like a really honest emotional
reaction like everybody calls Lex a
robot but it was like this beautiful
human thing and he's like whoa like and
then he processed it not as a [ __ ] you
but more like it's so sad that you feel
like you can't trust people
and of course yay is only thinking about
yay when he's been the only one looking
out for him and for all these years
maybe people have been making money off
of him and doing what they can to remove
resources from him and it's easy I
imagine when you feel taken advantage of
in every single relationship that you
have was used to kind of take something
from you it's one easy to be resentful
and feel like you're the only person in
this world that's just you and God
that's your only homie who will never
let you go
but it's also and he said this at one
point in the episode he goes
we have mutually aligned interests and
that's what I feel comfortable with and
that's the only way that he can have
trust
in a relationship with his wife even
brings it up like that a relationship
with his friends and think about how
lonely that is that every relationship
you have once you believe that people
are trying to take from you it's very
easy to go uh the few people who may or
may not be Jewish on my team are part of
a larger organization of Jews that are
just trying to extract
once that resentment is there and once
that loneliness is there and once that
abandonment is there
yeah he's like who loves you genuinely
your mom's gone yeah
you know your wife you may or may not
think that she's using you to get
somewhere yeah you might be using her to
get somewhere
now I'm not saying yay didn't ruin the
relationships on his own I'm sure he's
difficult guy to deal with it seems like
it I mean you could see the track record
of course everyone who's been by his
side is no longer by his side of course
and the people eventually it's you but
does it but not to cut you but like
I never saw that and yet I saw
confidence I saw arrogance I saw these
types of things but I never saw those as
covering up loneliness but even in the
drink camps interview he was like
complaining like oh you see when I was
going through it no one in the black
community stood by my side yeah you know
that would make sense
he's hurt man do you think that's I
think that's a consistent in most people
like super like not confidence but like
staunch like arrogance and like
bordering on like pathology is always
kind of rooted in some type of
insecurity and like conversation 100
yeah yeah the people that he's
mentioning when that's the part I
believe when he was talking about he's
jealous of these Jews and the way they
act this way and how they hold their own
like he's taught he's name dropping like
the azov family who once you're with
those people those are the both
mentoring mom and dad in the industry so
he's made it to the top of people that
are going to look after not just take
away from you so it's easy that you did
something to push away from management
to agents to business managers so that's
the part where it's like yeah you could
be lonely
I thought it was another cool thing that
Lex did when he said um you know he was
giving pushback to Jewish media and he
goes
he goes say their names I love that yeah
I thought it was really great right he
was like I like the most he's like don't
be a [ __ ] he's like be brave yeah say
the people's names that have hurt you
don't use this blanket term that's what
is going to be what breeds the hatred
towards a group of people who are
innocent in doing anything to you yeah
say those individuals and then they
didn't do it yeah he also said be the
change that you want to see it's like if
you don't like the industry you're a
billionaire now you can do the changes
you had that genius point yesterday you
told me yeah I don't know if Kanye has
given his artist their masters yet I
know he said he would I don't know that
he has you would think Kanye once it's
done and in writing would publish the
contracts this is the kind of guy you
would think Kanye is hey I'm giving you
your your Masters back I'm the owner I'm
Kanye I own good music you're common
you're Big Sean whoever why does Big
Sean still say he sold three million
dollars hasn't taken back what he said
on drink Champs at Connie was in
millions
so Kanye you complain about contracts
multiple times on Alex Friedman
interview you never said I gave my guys
their masters back so Lex Freeman asked
him about that he goes listen I was like
the face of a label but I wasn't
actually running the label the people
that were running the label were doing
it [ __ ] up and it's like it's your
label man you got your Masters back
right and you you could have it's a very
easy fight from there hey you could have
at least fought for your people which is
what you're saying you're doing now like
be the change you want to see and I
think that to Alex's Point earlier maybe
it was your point which is like
he wants to be the change he wants to
see for Kanye yeah and if there's a
trickle down that affects other people
that's cool but I gotta hit yay first
yeah you know what I mean I'm not really
going out of my way to help you all but
I did it first so y'all could do it
later y'all do it on your own though
just like me he's a clear narcissist who
doesn't want to take any accountability
and it's like I I feel a little bit bad
for him because I've seen like I was a
big Kanye fan I watch a lot of his
interviews you can see his like decline
in terms of even the way he's speaking
it's like he cannot stay focused on a
single thing like he can't even like
finish a single sentence and then he's
like off to the next thing like he's
jumping around and he even said in the
interview he's like hey I've been off my
meds for two years there you go like
that's not good
from a president who says he's
clinically bipolar that's not good he
doesn't he doesn't believe it anymore
he's because he's having a manic episode
and the last time he had an episode he
claimed he said he was bipolar he said
himself he was bipolar just came out of
his mouth but again when you're having
an episode you feel so good you're like
man I'm these [ __ ] telling me
I'm X Y and Z I'm not I feel great I
feel better than I've ever been because
I'm off those meds and again I think he
got out of the meds that Matt pavich
brought this up again those meds make
you fat and I think Kanye we know to be
a very vain guy and I could 100 see him
and his family supporting it the
Kardashians being like yeah you don't
need that might get fat
but it is amazing like
he's a he's a lightning rod oh like he
there are very few people like when they
want can make the entire world talk
about them he's historic in that sense
why is he able to do that I think he
Taps into a lot of people's like
internal desire to be seen as like the
Misunderstood genius because he's
undoubtedly a genius and he's
undoubtedly misunderstood you know what
I mean so I think everyone likes to see
themselves as like yo I'm I'm Harry
Potter I'm living under the stairs like
I don't get the respect that I deserve
I'm actually a genius I'm actually a
hero really won me with the Harry Potter
thing I was ready to push back I
appreciated otters this guy gets it
that's the story is like yo I'm just
like a kid from Chicago and I have this
Talent I'm not gonna respect that one
that I finally get it and then when I
get it I don't just like hide away I
actually keep pushing and I keep on
trying to make change and I keep saying
my opinion and speaking my voice and
it's really powerful to people I think
people see it and identify with it and
go that's the person that I perceive
myself to be in that I want to be one
day regardless of like what the message
is it's just seeing a man with purpose
on a mission that's overcoming odds and
obstacles and media and all these
external forces filled with self belief
in a way we all wish we were yeah
exactly that's really been the theme of
his music ever since the beginning and
that's why a lot of people gravitate to
it is the underdog he's always been the
underdog even when he was on top he was
still the underdog yeah he was still
think he's an underdog he's a
billionaire yeah well not now apparently
because he just that lost him his
billionaire status but yeah how are you
he always takes on new challenges and
then is a genius in those things he like
takes on music and is like this
unrespected producer that's like no I'm
a rapper and then he becomes an amazing
rapper that like makes these amazing
albums yeah and he's like oh I'm gonna
sell these 500 t-shirts and everyone's
like you're an idiot and then he makes
this giant clothing brand and he
continues to create odds for himself and
then beats them and I think people see
that they're like [ __ ] that is the cool
snack yeah so I get why his story is
like motivational for his journey yeah
why people allow you to people yeah
exactly literally it's like the Hero
Journey like he's created that for
himself and his life is like this
[ __ ] Shakespearean tale like it's
amazing I completely agree with all that
one small point of pushback I think us
buying into him is a genius Beyond
fashion and and even fashion genius I
don't know what that is but music he
that's I think we just let him be a
genius and everything and he kind of to
believe that we let them believe that
and I think that's what's making it I
think the genius
of fashion is not how the clothes fit or
how they look
it's convincing people to wear them yeah
because we'll wear anything yes we've
we're all old enough to go through
multiple style Cycles yeah baggy to
skinny to baggy and like we're old
enough to wear skinny during baggy and
then feel dumb yeah when we wore it and
felt cool or your favorite shirt all of
a sudden you wouldn't be caught dead and
you're like what this shirt's the same
yeah what changed so so weirdly the
design of clothes is arbitrary it is the
influence to get the cool people to wear
the clothes which is the greatest power
in fashion I'll say kind of arbitrary
but yeah well to a certain extent but I
mean he even talked about it in the The
Lex thing he was like I got our nose
reaction when I had all these people at
the easy show that's when he got the
yeah well from a business perspective
yeah well why is it valuable
from a business perspective because our
no knows that influencing other people
that are influencers to be at the show
to be at the easy show to wear the
Yeezys to walk the easiest the most
influential models singers everybody
once they're being influenced by this
guy and he doesn't have him
under a contract somewhere
that's a problem for him you got to keep
lvmh going yeah and if I don't own that
brand that everybody thinks is the next
brand now my [ __ ] is [ __ ] yeah so I
think at its core he understands what
what what moves fashion it's not the
[ __ ] cut I'm sorry designers it's not
the cut I think they know I think they
know it's a little bit don't take it all
the way I don't want to discredit I
don't want to discredit that as a skill
because it's an amazing yes it is like
uh there's different styles of painting
impressionist painting right there's
realism like there's all these different
styles and some people can do many
different ones like Picasso could paint
something so it looks like you yeah and
he could also do the what is the one
where it's like the cubism I think it's
called something like that like there
are different styles
it's getting people to buy into Picasso
is a genius painter that makes those
paintings valuable 100 there's a Gucci
billboard out there where they're
wearing the Clockwork Orange outfit have
you guys seen that I'm gonna watch Jack
from uh
they look exactly like trendy Jackson
you're talking about the one in
Lafayette right now yeah so funny shout
out to train a jack man I love yellow
goats but I watched Clockwork Orange in
the whatever 2004 in college and I was
like these guys look [ __ ] weird this
is Goofy I don't understand any of this
I'm walking by it it's on a Gucci below
board and I'm like she's kind of fire
now that you think I'm as dumb as
anybody else I'm just as much of a sheep
as anybody else but so much of fashion
the cotton [ __ ] matters but so much of
it is marketing and getting us to buy
and especially me because I'm the last
guy to get there so if you got me it's
you got everyone yeah I mean it has to
objectively be cool in some ways like it
can't be uncool but yeah ultimately cool
yeah but what makes it cool just that it
fits you no you said that no no Mark you
said this actually I remember
specificities clothes they're oversized
they don't even fit yeah yeah but like
I'm saying like he can't make something
that is like objectively ugly yes you
can you can no you son we're gonna use
your words because you made this you
made this argument it was um
about what may oh yeah what makes
something cool is the fact that it isn't
so everything starts as a rejection of
the norm right remember we were talking
about fashion it's a progression of the
normal like the way I've heard people
describe it is like it has to be right
on the edge of like the Overton window
of acceptability but pushing it far
enough that it's still nobody knows what
you're talking about look
not a single you was talking about
Ovaltine I don't know what the [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
I was positive for a second yeah
is it
everybody's wearing skinny jeans this is
fashion stupid just close yeah it's not
a reaction
I don't know what he's talking about
we're just trying to make it easier to
digest everybody's wearing skinny mm-hmm
the next cycle fashion will be baggy it
is predictable it doesn't happen every
single time because that's the rejection
of this thing right here what is baggy
while this is popular while Skinny's
popular what's baggy ugly
ugly or uncool yeah and then once the
cool people reject you this was your
point yeah I know but I'm saying that
there's trends like if you just like
break the trend in the middle of the
trend then people be like ah oh I got
you it's not there yet
like I'm saying like within a cycle you
can't just make anything
once Urban Outfitters it's like once
Urban outfit brand or whatever yeah then
people will be like oh it's everywhere
one skinny small brand now it's time to
break yeah exactly it's like you
couldn't just like when uh what was it
Ed Hardy got like made kids clothes or
whatever yeah then it was like okay it's
over like they couldn't just like keep
doing it and be like oh yeah let's just
make a new story like the stories
already run its course so that's the
only pushback I'm saying I even think
man in the middle and you couldn't
coordinate this but if you've got all
the the influencers in the middle of the
skinny jeans hype or even now the
baggage instinct is on the rise in the
middle of it if you got a bunch of
famous sexy people to just start wearing
skinny or just completely break the
trend the trend is over yeah whatever it
was it's now broken and now we're going
to this thing sure right because we're
all like I guess you just got to see it
enough times to be like yeah [ __ ] is
actually fire sure sure to get those
people to be influenced though like can
you influence them in the middle of that
thing to [ __ ] up their potential brain
exactly and then if you're able to then
you have influence to set the trend and
then you are the trendsetter therefore
the trend is changing yeah but
ultimately you're buying the story yes
like when it comes to fashion and like
most artists it comes to life yeah the
story man but yeah the Lex interview is
very interesting and I'm glad Lex had
them on yeah at first I was I was like
yo why is he doing this like I was like
are you just going after [ __ ] numbers
like what's going on Lex like and then I
then I was
told that he's Jewish and I was like
that makes sense I want Kanye to speak
to a thoughtful
smart Jewish guy you didn't know Lex
Friedman was Jewish no no
isn't Friedman a Jewish name very true I
thought so it's like super Julie it's
like one of the my name's Julie yeah
it's like one of those names where it
could be both but I'm not Jewish but you
are though you just don't accept it
you're not Jew you're Jewish about Jews
we'll see if I'm Jewish let's see let's
see who owns the banks boys I love Jews
there you go I'm not Jewish at all
but uh but yeah I don't know I did then
I thought from that perspective it was
like a really cool conversation and I
thought he did it really well where
early on he's very nice very friendly
we're having the conversation and I was
kind of waiting I was like yo Lex gives
pushback when is this coming and then it
started about 20 30 minutes in whatever
it was he was like now that was a
horrible apology there's no G we need to
talk about this Jewish media thing call
out the individual is not the group
that's cowardly yeah he said some harsh
[ __ ] yeah but it was good yeah it was
good go check it out necessary yeah yeah
go check it out and we gotta have Lex on
the Pod when he's in town hell yeah